the tory party is absolutely imploding
um they know they're out of ideas and
they're out of touch if they had any
decency they'd get out the way for the
next labour government because what
happened here in wakefield was people
exercising their judgment on this
conservative government and voting no
confidence but for me and the labour
party this is very important because for
two years uh we've been turning our
party around uh and we were able to show
the voters in wakefield that we are a
confident party we're a united party and
that we are laser-like focused on the
issues that affect working people in
wakefield and that's why they put their
faith in simon that's why they put their
faith in the labour party don't you yet
have a problem though because i just
said people are voting no confidence
that you would see it in boris jones now
back in 2012 let me remind you of
flavors by election success in corby
12.7 swing exactly what you got here can
you remind me of what the subsequent
general election was well yes of course
but look you know i've had no end of uh
commentators of polls for two years as
we rolled up our sleeves and done the
hard work in relation to the labour
party and now we've had the sort of
swing that puts us on track not just for
a labor government from majority labor
government so this is hugely significant
for the labour party and i'm so proud
that we can present that confident
labour party utterly focused on the
voters that's what i wanted to achieve
and this is evidence evidence that we're
on course for a labour government but
some of those voices are saying that
they are defecting to you as a protest
this time it's a lack of enthusiasm for
boris johnson not enthusiasm on the back
of that result here that swing i'm
afraid that argument just doesn't carry
people came across the labour party
because the labour party was talking to
them and for them thank you very much
thank you